je sais pas où et monsieur fagots je
sais ce que je veux pour cette ville
voilà et donc je veux du respect mutuel
entre les uns et les autres mais ça
passe ça passe sur les objets qu'on
jette sur la voie publique tiens il
faudrait dire à vos équipes qui ramasse
les affiches wanted et arrache ses 530
là dessus s'est passé à 130 euros
les affiches et qui sont quand même très
on respecte donc pour demander qui
causait tant qu'ils liquident qui fait
des délits paye vous serez peut-être à
monter ses biens dont le porte bon ça ou
la cadette répondant à la fierté
maintenant on fait pas la rigole pas
avec la télé vous faire des ennemis
deviennent coup fait fait en sorte déjà
des données spatiales de palmer
parallèlement aux parents rôle des
parents qui est primordial des
enseignants des éducateurs des
médiateurs que la police ait déroulant
renforcée qu'elle travaille de nuit
qu'elle travaille beaucoup plus dans les
quartiers en lien avec la police
municipale et c'est tout ça ne vous
paraît la police nationale de la police
nationale pour se protéger pour inspirer
le respect auquel premier tour est large
et en travers
côté ravivant sur une écuelle monsieur
phal robin ont bombardé au raz de marée
très brave est bon